hi everyone i'm very excited to see so
many of you who are interested in code
reviews which is kind of a boring topic
you would assume so let's make this a
bit interactive by show of hands who of
you is a data scientist
yeah well great thanks for being here
um
who of you has some experience with code
reviews
also good and who of you who is a data
scientist does regularly do uh code
reviews so regularly means like once or
twice a month at least
okay
yeah well um there's uh there's room for
more so let's see how that looks after
the talk um anyway let's get into it
and uh what i want to start with is a
look at some pros and cons of reviewing
a piece of software
why would i do code reviews for one um
there's
improve the code clarity so if i as a
reviewer understand the code that the
author has produced
then it's more likely that someone else
is able to understand what's happening
there in a month or half a year or even
a year
next thing they might uncover errors
so getting a buck or finding a bug in in
production is yeah well not so good
it's costly and sometimes or i think
many of you who did code reviews have
found some error
doing doing that code review and this is
always a good thing
next thing is that i as a reviewer
probably learn something while doing the
um doing the code review so i i learn
what is happening in the in the piece of
software
i might learn something that the author
is doing so
learning about a new function a tool
some design pattern that the author is
using
and last thing well literally everyone
says that i should do code reviews
on the con side is yeah well i don't
want to i have meetings i have other
tasks to do i want to work on a very
cool thing
do some research so yeah well code
reviews are tedious and i don't want to
spend my time
on that
and
so with all these advantages and yeah
one point against it of course the
conclusion is i won't do code reviews
um but what about actually
what about code reviews for data science
work so meaning exploratory data
analyses prototyping a model wrangling
the data for that model visualizations
and so on
well i think the pros don't really
change
the only difference and you see that
maybe on the bottom that we don't have
that point here anymore i would say that
it's rather a con so i haven't i have
hardly heard anyone say that i should do
a code review as a data scientist
and you can see that as a con
but actually in seriousness
the code that we produce at data as data
scientists um often yeah is is some
prototype and will never end up in in
the production system as it is
it will get
updated some data engineer machine
learning
machine learning engineer maybe takes a
look at it refactors it a bit makes it
more robust and so on
and so why would i spend time on
something that
changes eventually
moreover
when we're talking about analyses um the
work is often a one-off of thing you
produce some results you report these
results to your stakeholders and then
this code gets put into yeah the desk
basically and forgotten and no one sees
it anymore
so why should i spend
my time on that
um so we could argue that re reviewing
data science work is yeah some kind of
waste of time and that that keeps
us from doing some other cool stuff like
working on a newest model
and
therefore the conclusion again is that i
will not do code reviews
and yet i think
that having someone else review your
work is as important in data science as
it is in software engineering
and let me show you why i think that is
by starting with why they're important
in software development
and this kind of takes up the points
that we had previously
so first of all
and yeah this is kind of an implicit
thing i don't think that we are really
um yeah aware of it when doing code
reviews but we want to check that the
goal that we defined in yeah some
tickets some some tasks a story is
actually fulfilled by the piece of
software by the artifact that the author
has produced
next
we probably all agree that
detecting bugs is yeah not really great
and in in the production system
and yeah we had that before one way to
mitigate this is apart from rigorous
testing also having code reviews
and of course you'll never catch
anything
and this should also but not be the
aspiration
and aside from that misunderstandings
also can happen maybe the goal hasn't
been specified clear enough
in the story or
you have a new team member and he
doesn't
they don't really know
everything about how it works in a team
and then misunderstandings can just
happen but code reviews are also um yeah
an option
uh or a possibility
to detect these misunderstandings to
uncover those next point is a knowledge
transfer
i as a reviewer i learned to understand
what is actually happening in that code
and yeah i'm then the author is not the
only one
who knows what's happening and someone
else can work with it in a later stage
maybe even when the author is not around
anymore
penultimate point is feedback for
architectural or design decisions
code could for example fit better in
another place or
it may be reasonable to use a class
instead of just collecting
yeah your function some helper script or
whatever or you have some maybe an api
endpoint and yeah it's more convenient
to use when you would
add an optional argument to that
endpoint and so on and so forth
and these discussions are really
essential when doing code reviews
and finally
we also have um yeah the option or the
possibility to improve our code and our
coding practice
one i as a reviewer can do that by
learning from the author or the author
can benefit from my knowledge by maybe
hinting at some function that
they
[Music]
implemented yeah on their
own if we think about these points um or
these aspects i think we could say that
these are also
essential in large parts um to yeah the
kind of work we do as data scientists so
these exploratory analyses the
prototypical tasks and so on
however
in my opinion and from my experience the
traditional code review practice is not
applicable to this yet typical data
science work
and the reason for this conclusion lies
and that's what from that's from what i
experienced and what i learned
is the different focus
areas that we put or that we have
between writing proper software that
ends up in production on the one side
and prototyping or doing analyses on the
other side
and here on this slide i want to give
you a sense of what
these differences are by giving you some
questions that you can maybe think of
when doing code reviews
for software engineering or data
engineering machine learning engineering
we have is the artifact functional is it
um is it doing what it's supposed to do
and is it working smoothly with um yeah
within the system
um that we put it in
are there bugs i think we have that had
we had that before
and another important one is our coding
guidelines and quality standards matt is
this tested rigorously enough
and last question that you could ask is
can someone else then the author work
on the artifact
um yeah
no it should never be the case that only
one person knows what's happening there
data science the questions are a bit
different in my opinion
one we have is a chosen approach
comprehensible and clear that's the
algorithm
that has been chosen makes sense in the
specific use case that it has been
chosen for
um are the evaluation uh yeah criteria
the correct ones in that context and so
on
does the data have any specifics to it
so yeah we're in real life and real life
data
never is clean it never is perfect and
there are some things that you need to
take into account when working with the
data and that
yeah review is kind of a check or a
possibility to check
whether these peculiarities have been
taken
into account
next one are the results that
a model produces possible or that you
find out during your analysis and
reporting to stakeholders because that
can be kind of dangerous
when your results are not plausible or
even incorrect and stakeholders make
their decisions based on these decisions
that can become expensive
and last one can someone else then the
author explained a concept
and
here it's not so much about all the
technical details
but more about
um yeah
the model the evaluation criteria
baselines and so on
so more on a higher level
so
i would still say that we have for
software engineering
code reviews
and but i would call it uh on the other
side for data scientists
of or for data science peer reviews
because
um
i think that
that works kind of similar um like we
are reviewing scientific work or like
the paper reviewing process that you
know from many academic or also
industrial conferences
and so
yeah i think we can transfer these
changes
in the focus also on the aspects of for
code reviews what code reviews are for
to yeah data science
and
firstly
we have again the check on whether the
defined task has been completed and i
suppose that you would agree here
that is still being relevant and
important
we can also keep the second point with a
little adjustment and that is to look
um
to yeah into logical errors and what i
mean by um logical errors
is to focus more on the correct usage of
algorithms or evaluation metrics
um so meaning to choose the right
methods for the right use case and not
so much the
yeah technical implementation of that
of course if you find some errors in the
implementation um yeah that's always a
good thing
but that's not the focus here
the next point knowledge transfer is
also something that we can keep as it is
and as i said earlier we want to make
sure that someone else apart from the
author really understands the concept
upon a penultimate point so the second
to last point
needs a bit more tweaking
done
we don't
need so for need to focus so much on why
technology a has been chosen over
technology b
why we designed the api in that way and
if it needs some more endpoints or
arguments
instead we should rather focus on
whether the approach is fulfilling the
task it is supposed to fulfill
so meaning why has algorithm x been
chosen
for this model uh to set up the model
why did we choose this subset of um of
this specific subset of the data um for
yeah training the model or for doing
that um for doing that analysis and so
on
is the baseline um yeah the the right
one for the use case or are there even
better ones
and i think that these questions are
much more important than yeah having the
having feedback on the design
and lastly
although i think
that it's always important to improve
your code and your coding practice
i would say that for these kind of
tasks it's much more important
to reproduce the results
so you should check whether you should
you can run as a regulator code and get
to the same results because works on my
machine it's just not enough
so
i hope that i convinced you now that
code reviews or peer values in that
sense are also a good thing
to
yeah for data scientists and that you
want to yeah really get into it
um but you might ask how do i do this
even and um
i put together something that might help
you out with that
so
i put together a code review checklist
and you can find that on my github repo
which yeah and this checklist tries to
put
the points that i just talked about
into yeah some concrete steps so for
example the
reducibility part what a word
is here
as a second point you run the code you
see if that even yeah gets the result
and uh you check the result or for
example um yeah the part about
understanding everything
ask questions
ask the
ask the author to be
clearer about things to document more
and so on
if you want to get a bit more into code
reviews i can recommend you the blog by
michael lynch
who is a software developer and who
wrote some really nice
articles about code reviews and i don't
agree with everything
that he wrote about but i personally
took a lot
from these blog posts for my own code
revenue practice
and yeah in summary you could say
that
we we should be more empathetic
when doing code reviews and also always
be mindful of of the fact that there is
a human being sitting on the other side
of the screen
yeah just a note the first two links are
actually for reviewers as whereas the
third article is more for
the author
and yeah i think the title is very very
cool
now as a last thing
i want to give you yeah some tools that
you can maybe work with that make this
still kind of tedious task a bit less
tedious
and um yeah i'm assuming that you're
working with some kind of versioning
system and in that case it is git
git has some really
some very nice functionality which is
the pre-commit hooks
and these
yeah give give you the possibility
to
run a predefined set of tools with every
commit
and some of the tools that i would
recommend for data science work is
for one the nb convert
since in jupyter notebooks um
you normally have this ipython notebook
format and this is really not um yeah
not easy to review so gitlab and also
github cannot really
show the divs for these
for this format and with mb convert
you can convert this these ipython
notebooks to
the percent format so that means the dot
pi
suffix is what you get out and this is
uh much more easy to review so you're
doing your review actually a big favor
here
another thing are code formatters
so
in the best case you and your team
agreed on some style guides
and black and ice sword as well as a
linter flake 8 are some tools that
ensure that these star guides are kept
another thing um is yeah for actually
the gitlab and github interfaces and
yeah this is now assuming that you are
kind of familiar with uh with these or
at least with the merge request
interface if not there is a link on the
bottom
where you can read up on on the merge
requests in gitlab at least
so
there is the comment field in
in merge requests and some tools that i
find very useful
i can show you here
there's the code suggestion and this is
my personal favorite to be honest
if you click that the lines of code that
you selected are actually pasted into
that field
and you can uh edit them and then add
this to to the review ad this is a
comment and the author only needs to
apply this suggestion
and spares to copy the code
another one which is relatively new is
that you can actually mark multiple
lines
when doing
yeah when doing code reviews
and this is also quite neat because you
can then give the reviewer a bit more
yeah yeah
the reviewer the context or the scope of
what you're actually commenting
and the last one here
is this at the bottom
also
more or less new
is the possibility to add comments to a
review so that means that you can
comment in a batch and don't spam your
author
because
actually when you
when you're getting notified you would
get notified about
each individual comment and that can
yeah be a bit annoying
and it's mostly also not necessary um so
i yeah heavily recommend to use that add
to review option
github also has these functionalities
sometimes they look a bit different
the code suggestion is actually not an
icon there but you as
you see in the brackets you can also use
that here
and
the very last thing i want to show you
is the mark viewed option here
which
is especially helpful when you have very
big reviews um and this is actually a
real review that i did
yeah
there are if you have so many files you
can easily get lost um what you actually
have already looked at
and this little checkbox then collapses
just the file and yeah helps you in
keeping an overview
and
with that i would like to thank you for
your attention
and yeah i
am available on linkedin on twitter
you have my email there
and i look forward to your questions
thank you
[Applause]
thank you very much we already have the
first question
so which tool would you use for
peer reviewing the elements that are not
version controlled like the data and the
trained models
so trained models
is something i wouldn't uh really review
directly but more about the
metrics that that i get um or the code
so yeah if if you're tracking metrics
maybe mflow is something
helpful
and the data well that's also in the
code so
normally we have the different kind of
filters maybe as a sql code may or sql
queries maybe as python code and then
you
also yeah see from that
but what the data is about
okay
what would you say is a reasonable theme
size for which code reviews make sense
are standardized code review process
feasible in small teams of two or three
people
yes
it's a short answer so i think um
yeah starting from two people
um yeah it's um
yeah sensible to do code reviews i mean
it slows you down of course it keeps you
from other tasks but in the end you just
yeah you only benefit from it
how to deal with colleagues that don't
care for having their outputs
peer-reviewed without using authority
[Laughter]
well
honestly
have a talk with your managers i think
the only tip that that i can give or
if you're working in an
yeah
in an agile environment maybe there's a
scrum master or some agile coach
but yeah
that's that's a tricky one
and a situation that you don't want to
get into
different focus doesn't the data
scientist extend the software software
engineer list are there bugs seems to
very seems to be very relevant for data
scientists
of course yeah you could also see it as
an extension i would say
[Music]
bugs are well
they are not so common in in these data
science
tasks
and
more relevant in the um
in the production environment so yeah
depends on how you how you look at it i
would say
shall the peer review be done by a data
scientist as well or a data engineer or
even a soft engineer
it's clearly a data scientist
because mostly data scientist so
they are in the best position um to do
these kind of reviews um since they're
also
more or less deep in in
yeah in the stuff in in the models and
and so on
how do you prioritize ongoing tests and
code review how deep should a review go
aka how much time do you recommend to
invest per week for review
it depends
so
normally when i have a review it takes
yeah more or less a day i would say in
the week
luckily um you don't have
i don't have a review every week but
more or less every second week
so in the end it's it's okay
but it really depends on
on
yeah the size of the review what i can
maybe recommend is to yeah split it up
into
several chunks
i personally can only um concentrate or
focus for maybe an hour one and a half
at a time on on chord reviews because
they are yeah quite take quite some
energy
yeah but
yeah that's i think that's all i can say
to that okay that's like we have a
similar question here what are usually
what do you usually define as the
response
responsibility of the peer reviewer how
to write responsibilities on reviews and
reviews reviews taking too long
uh i don't
get the question really
so
maybe that's is that person in the
yeah
very difficult to to understand you with
a mask so for example in
in the presentation that you mentioned
you said that one responsibility of the
reviewer is ensuring that the logic is
indeed implemented as wanted right
is the responsibility of the reviewer
then getting the tasks running the like
everything by themselves or should the
responsibility
of providing these
numbers and the notebooks showing the
tasks
be on the writer themselves
definitely on the writers so
they should make sure that everything
runs correctly
of course
we're not perfect and some sometimes um
it yeah they're just errors so you as a
reviewer needs to rerun that stuff but
in the first place it needs to be
provided by by the by the author
does it answer your question
at which state of the project would you
propose to do a peer review at the end
of the merge request might be very large
and tip here
split it up
if possible
um
if if you see a good
point in between to have someone look at
it
then try that out but from my experience
or in yeah we we do that at the end
when the merge request is open
and the task is is completed
what is the usual format of code files
that you imagine doing a code review
on when keeping it in mind some of the
guidelines you offer jupiter notebook
can you repeat that yeah what is the
usual format of code files that you
imagine doing a code review
when keeping in mind some of the
guidelines you offer
um
so if i get the question correctly then
i would answer with uh try as uh try to
keep uh yeah to to keep as little or as
few ipython notebooks as possible so
i mean i'm i'm a python coder and we're
all python coordinators we're here at
the conference
so
yeah
use python files um yeah
this would be my recommendation i'm not
sure if i i got that question really
it was an anonymous offer maybe
yeah
if that was someone online
please search out and i mean we can just
discuss that later on
a lot of data scientists also write
great code how do you categorize
developers
[Laughter]
how do i categorize developers
yes
i don't know
okay maybe
rhymer
no
maybe he's gone
okay
in data in data science should there be
supplementary document that explain the
method data results to help the review
um yeah of course
so what we are
doing often in the project is to write
some documentation apart out from the
from the code so
um yeah some markdown files some
conference page whatever you're using um
which documents
the process and the results
um and the parameters you have um yeah
and
that yeah helps for one the reviewer and
also everyone else who is
later referring to to what you're
producing there
okay that's end of it thank you very
much